a United States congresswoman was a
victim of a racist incident inside the
Capitol Building I was walking from the
house building on Capitol Hill to the
capol and a man a white guy stopped me
and told me I could not get into the
members elevator and you know we have uh
pens and I was going to vote and he
blocked me from getting into the
elevator and told me I was not a member
of Congress and it was for members only
I said sir I'm a member of Congress and
he I showed him my pen and he said whose
pen did you steal now this an example of
what personal racism is and how people
of color constantly have to deal with
this each and every day who was this
random white guy blocking the elevator
just a guy was that was it a security
guard and if it was a security guard did
you report this incident to his
superiors is the guy fired and and if
he's a security guard that he when he
works there you how could he not
recognize you and know that you're a
representative of uh and and I mean was
this his first day on the job